[Applause]
will you tell everybody where you got
the inspiration for these cakes because
i think the story's so great yes totally
well my entire life my business my
everything is inspired actually by
birthdays and the joy it brings to
celebrate with people together
for all of that and the one memory that
i always have apart from
you know cake moment is a pinata moment
i grew up in mexico and that was just
the most yeah
that was just
that was just the most fun part you know
going up to something and knowing that
there's surprises inside and getting to
break it open and we're all hitting it
to see i don't know there was such a fun
moment to me that i wanted to combine it
with my other love of cake you know at
first i put big candies in it didn't
really work they all got stuck and
somehow we went smaller smaller smaller
candies and we got to
sprinkles literally just a lot of
sprinkles so that when you cut the cake
open it really is a pinata
it pours out it's mellifluous
all right well amira what kind of cake
are we making today okay well i know you
love daisies so i do they're my favorite
flower and connecting their flowers
we're making daisy cakes so i'm going to
walk you through it we have started by
already stacking a few colors here you
could always do any fun colors of food
coloring and i have our cream cheese
frosting here and by the way if you
aren't great at baking but you still
think this is fun start with a box mix
cake like you can literally do this
at home on your own and it's super fun
for this one we're doing five layers but
you could definitely do six layers which
is our signature one there you go fill
it with yeah you can pour it all in and
don't be scared the more the better
and just quickly i've domed this one
just so we have a little flower pot but
i really believe that it should be more
about the mess and the fun because you
can cover it in sprinkles and you love
it anyway
so right now we're crumb coating which
means we're just doing a thin layer of
frosting on the outside okay
i think i'm gonna oh oh i know i know
how to fix it ready you guys close your
eyes
drew is the most amazing
i mean who is it
thank you what are you thank you
perfect
we're just gonna completely skip to
drew's level there you go so perfect
right here she has now taught us how to
frost the outside of a cake that's right
and with so much grace and poise and we
have here is our little cookie crumbs or
chocolate cookie crumbs i just put them
in a bag smash them up you could do this
for anything and we're going to do yep
yep exactly oh i'm just going to add
adhesive i'm just i'm just having a
little glue aka frosting your frosting
is truly one of the best frostings that
has ever existed in the cake industry
and i do think your secret weapon is
cream cheese yes exactly
cream cheese
i'm going to have a different route than
you mine's interpreting i think you're
so artistic
um so i've made chocolate flowers here
that we can just they're very very
dainty because they're chocolate flowers
but um you could also if you break it
you know it's great you could just eat
it true i think that you're crushing it
thank you well i am crushing it but not
in the right way
well it is time to cut the
cake cut out the cake cut cut the cake
cut that cake has that cake touch that
cake
now i've i've also learned that you need
to the first cut is the deepest
literally
yes
[Music]
cheers
cheers
i'm near cheers
i love you so happy birthday
[Music]
that means it's giveaway time all right
at first we made a flower themed cake
and flowers are perfect for any birthday
celebration and venus a floor has
beautiful arrangements that are perfect
for gifting so everyone in our audience
is getting a 150 gift card
um i bet women fall into you all the
time um and these flowers last a very
long time
and to match we have a copy of rebel
homemaker which i wrote with pilar
valdez going to all of you
so
everyone in the audience gets a copy all
right be sure to catch foodtastic
streaming on disney plus and get all of
amira's products at william sonoma and
her website and everything should be a
flower shop world you'll be happier in
it
[Music]
you